welcome to the f words I'm searching the
country to find our best local
restaurants
[Music]
pendant restaurants serve fantastic food
in the heart of our local communities
and each week I'm choosing two of these
unsung culinary Heroes to compete in the
f word kitchen to win this is the the
biggest moment of my life so far Bouchon
Bistro from hexham near Newcastle was
crowned the epworth's best local French
restaurant
welcome
from Birmingham took the Indian title
The Sensation is absolutely amazing
and the Italian prize went to salvos
from Leeds
last week Simply Thai from Teddington
stormed the leaderboard taking joint
first place if you put your heart and
soul into everything you can achieve who
will be crowned the epworth's best local
restaurant tonight we go Spanish El Gato
negro from Ripon in Yorkshire is in the
ring with Lolo Rocco from South London
one of the greatest Spanish Delicacies
Goose Barnacles but are they worth
risking my life for oh my God this is
insane
will Kelly book crack when she takes me
on in the recipe challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
good excited yes now we do have the best
two Spanish restaurants here head to
head and this is quite weird because
we've got two English running a Spanish
restaurant and two Spanish running the
most amazing Spanish restaurant Antonio
are you ready yeah yeah Simon in terms
of confidence where did you sit in one
to ten ten ten yeah 15. 15 out of 10.
now okay it's a competition make this
the best service of your lives yes and
you'll be leaving here as a winner
tonight to fight for the Spanish title
this is how they got here
foreign
website and nominate your favorite local
restaurants the response has been
absolutely phenomenal
you told us about nearly 5 000 different
places you love to eat
and from your nominations it's clear you
go Loco for Tapas
so I asked my f word team to help me
Whittle down your nominations to find
the very best Spanish contenders
we're traveling across the country
really putting these nominated
restaurants under severe scrutiny
Spanish restaurants from Scotland to
the places you love to eat as we
searched it soon became clear that two
restaurants were in A League of Their
Own in Ripon West Yorkshire El Gato
negro is a very Spanish restaurant run
by a very passionate northerner I
suppose you want to expect a northerner
to be cooking Spanish food but you know
it works and I love it I love the
products I love I love the people I love
the food and so you know we're
passionate about it Simon Shaw has an
impressive pedigree he was the executive
chef at Harvey Nichols in London but
gave up at glamorous City Life to open a
Spanish restaurant in the country
there's nothing better that I love than
to be in the middle of Barcelona sat
with a beer eating a plate of padron
peppers and I thought you know the
people of Yorkshire deserve this
Simon is a culinary Pioneer and exactly
what I'm looking for hello
how are you sir
I very well how are you
I can't wait to see if an English Chef
can deliver stunning Spanish food
good to see look at the size of this
kitchen what in the hell are you doing
up here like most restaurants says I
wanted to open a restaurant didn't have
enough money to do in London right so
I'm actually from around here Amelia
walks in I think it was the right place
for us local lad Matt Healy is the sous
chef he knows the quality of Elgato
Negros Cuisine can win over any critic
if somebody said to me it's Allah
on a Saturday night and it'll change
your mind
head chef Simon Cohen's the restaurant
with flamboyant Welshman Chris Williams
a former colleague from Harvey niggs
seven of I could have a 30 tempestuous
relationship between me I can flip but
some Consignment faced with so many
tempting dishes I want to taste a bit of
everything starting with the anchovy
crostini good food pretty good food uh
clean great flavors simply done more of
a traditional Spanish tapas and yeah
fast this is cooked freshly great
flavors great balance one hell of a
talented Chef we we've got our sights
set on winning it so it means a lot hell
of a lot we win it would be the dogs so
first impression this place is warm and
Incredibly warm having searched across
the country there's only two restaurants
going through
cook
in the f word restaurant and there it's
50 Discerning diners that are you know
quite full-on
and
congratulations you're one of them
back in London really yeah lentil season
brilliantly congratulations three zo
wonderful prawns wonderful
[Music]
good
representing Elgato negro it's just it's
up there it's up there with anything
I've done before so
very pleased to have one of your Idols
tell you that the food is fantastic it's
just
you can't clean top that talented team
and how weird is that amazing Tapas not
one Spanish person cooking it anywhere
that needs to be celebrated big time so
El Gato negro is through and from your
nominations I found a worthy opponent to
take them on
[Music]
South London is home to Lola Rocco a
short walk from where I live
[Music]
it's a modern Spanish restaurant run by
Antonio and Christina Antonio I'm and I
we got together because of the love
the fiery couple from Barcelona have a
passionate relationship in and out of
the kitchen I went into the kitchen
and they told me you know get
also please you know calm down and you
know he took it on board
hello
how are you I'm quite fine nice to see
you nice to see you
Christina could have seen my day what a
little place Christina Prides herself on
the fact that all her staff are from
Spain
[Music]
her husband Antonio is the head chef
he's bold and experimental in the
kitchen with a passion for contemporary
Tapas what's all this is
bloody hell yeah you make lollipops
that's incredible
Antonio insists on importing products
from Spain to create a truly authentic
experience for his customers
yes
[Music]
this is for
yes this is from Salamanca beautiful and
that's 21 days old yeah yeah I'd like to
start without the octopus a little bit
of chicken and a little taste of the
boiler
first up for me grilled octopus and
potatoes bravas
[Music]
next the suckling pig
and finally Lobster paella
honestly keep on pitching myself I'm
about to see Rise not Barcelona
authentic Spanish I mean properly
Spanish tapas done brilliantly well
extraordinary well we just hope that
we'll go through the Spanish category
yes has been one of the toughest
categories across the country so
congratulations because you are through
to the upward restaurants
honestly I had an exceptional lunch yeah
congratulations that was a short break
beautiful yeah and I've been a big big
big admirer of proper Tapas beautifully
done congratulations thank you very much
thank you thank you really good thank
you
well done we are very very happy but we
love this this city we love this country
we love the customers you know
definitely the right decision mate and
more importantly I'm so frustrated you
know I've been living here for seven
years they've been here for three years
I've never even noticed them and that's
what this competition is all about yeah
unsung heroes cooking authentic proper
Spanish tappers like that deserve to be
recognized
[Music]
so I've chosen two remarkable Spanish
restaurants from your nominations
well the f word diners prefer Elgato
negro's classic tapas
or Lola Rocco's contemporary menu
we crowned the F word's best local
Spanish restaurant we're about to find
out
[Music]
next on the menu the Spanish teams go
head to head in the f word kitchen guys
may this count yes there's only four
points different in this
a dice with death
of a very special Spanish delicacy
all that [__] work for these things
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back in London at the f word
restaurants
tonight we're going Spanish
after searching for months all over the
country we Whittle down your nominations
to find F word's best two local Spanish
restaurants Elgato negro and Yorkshire
and Lalo Rocco in South London okay guys
Antonio four covers on table one please
four prawns four fish two four cheers
excellent El Gato stand by here don't
stop working here on all the fun five
five prawns yes five sea bass five
churros we're Chef yes chef thank you
right Simon the sticker Behind These
prawns yeah I mean for me I like a lot
of caramelization on them you really
want to chase that char grill flavor
yeah and you'd have the heads on why is
that yeah there's all the good flavors
in there great flavors ahead as a
northerner Simon has a no-nonsense
approach to Spanish tapas
maybe in the Yorkshire Countryside but
Simon's determined to bring home the
taste of Spain a lot of people that come
here actually ask if the chef's vanish
so to be able to say actually no he's
from Hall actually he's quite a good
[Music]
it's like a little slice of barcelara in
West Yorkshire which you just would not
expect it's a delight to have it so
close to where we live for Elgato negro
starter Simon marinades prawns in lemon
garlic and Thyme and then griddles them
them in chorizo butter and serve them
with frittata sauce parsley oil and
balsamic vinegar drizzing over the
remaining chorizo butter
what's in the butter in the butter fine
iced chili paprika chorizo Cabernet
Sauvignon vinegar and red wine
and the sausage the puree of the streets
of sausage just just put in the oven
under salad just to release the oils out
of it too much and then you're blitzing
it and passing through it
yeah I'm telling you would you say that
salmon flavor is better we like the the
the the plain flavor not like spicy or
just strong and sometimes yeah yeah
it's for beginners no for beginners yeah
yeah sounds like a child so it's like
your baby yeah okay
yeah excellent so I didn't realize that
you were connected to Antonio because
you said you cook like a baby
I don't know Antonio has a unique
contemporary style of cooking
opening a restaurant has been Antonio's
dream since he was a child growing up in
Spain
the family-run business has a warm
atmosphere which is a big hit with the
locals
they love Antonio's authentic tappers
with a modern twist it is best
I have ever had in London for Antonio
starter he coats King prawns in flower
dips them in batter and deep fries he
skews a hole in the prawns and inserts a
pipette of chive mayonnaise the prawns
are served on a bed of wild salad and a
side of tomato and red pepper peperada
some people see and say
and the wall is green now I said
so the paprika at the end what kind of
paprika is that what is that it's the
Picante Picante that's a smoked paprika
yeah yeah is that class for beginners as
well paprika or not yeah the hot paprika
yes [__] you know you can't win either
way can you paprika if you beat him
tonight you can have a big [__] smile
on your face from here to here you know
the biggest box of paprika and the
biggest package you've ever seen I'm
going to send them to you in the post
very nice they all look like the spraded
little green trees
right in Spain Goose Barnacles are known
as the truffles of the sea and here's
why
[Music]
the Atlantic Ocean is a chef's dream
galithia on the northwest coast of Spain
is home to Classic Spanish ingredients
like prawns but that's not all
the bursting with some of the best
seafood in the world the only problem is
the Spanish don't like exporting it so
if you really want to try it you've got
to come here and taste it for yourself
this region is famous for seafood
the shellfish popular with the locals
you'll only find in a few places around
the world
now these are huge delicacy here
pathodairs commonly known as goose
Barnacles now let's be honest they don't
exactly look like the most appetizing of
seafood do they I think they look more
like [__] Janet's reporter's toenails
however the secret here is to just twist
quickly and Pull and out comes this
amazing delicacy flavor
um
in terms of taste delicious cross
between a razor clam and a sort of
cockle stroke muscle and here's the good
news 300 Euros a kilo
hmm for bowl of toenails
wow
these incredibly expensive shellfish may
look weird but they taste delicious
the big question is why do they cost
three times more than fresh Lobster
we came clear when I met up with local
fishermen Andres in a secret location
further up the coast
now what in the hell are they doing down
there are they collecting perseveres
actually my God it is mad it is crazy so
what they're doing they're just dangling
over the side of the the rock yeah they
keep jumping from one rock to another
and collecting from there actually it's
it's very very dangerous and many people
have died collecting per service many
people have done yeah many people a year
the way he jumps I mean it's so [__]
dangerous now yeah it is it is actually
I wouldn't do it myself
this amazing delicacy is found below the
water line stuck firm to the foot of the
craggy Spanish Coast
but dodging the weight like a matador
seemed to step too far even for these
Exquisite little shellfish
and this spot wasn't actually where the
best ones were hiding
this was
to get down there and the goose
Barnacles were at the bottom of this 300
foot cliff deep beneath the crashing
waves
fishermen like Angel and Javier risked
their lives almost every day to get
their hands on them
because that's where the best ones are
this is
good ones in there the more danger the
best per service the more dangerous yeah
can you you need to see a doctor
the more the goose Barnacles are pounded
by the waves the more muscle they need
to cling onto the cliff so the juicier
fatter and tasty they become
how you getting them off they're
attached hard
that's for taking tires off a car
no now you uh you hit the rock and the
idea with pessimist is to get a bit of
rock underneath them so they don't die
straight away is that right
so crowbar oh [__] and the pouch other
side yeah yeah that's all they take
that's it yeah that's it and a pair of
Converse and a pair of Converse
these are certainly one of the most
extraordinary Delicacies I've ever come
across
to do is survive long enough to get my
hands on them
be the most dangerous thing I've ever
done
okay Simon last table
yeah good yeah it's not a race geyser
not a race every plate that went out
from this kitchen looked fantastic yeah
really good job yeah well done thank you
Antonio well done finished okay it's
well done sure
but the prawns um the tree so I thought
might overpower and the flavor of the
prawns but it didn't at all it was like
an infusion it was perfect I could have
eaten it again I thought the dish was
actually really good I thought the
presentation was quite nice
um the only thing I would say is
although the prawns are quite well
cooked the chorizo butter wasn't that
flavoursome
good to see you welcome beautiful yeah
thank you very much nice to see you all
how do you think Antonio Zoo very well
does it make you feel incredibly proud
and in terms of the prawns you ate
tonight how were they how will the mix
chorizo with seafood because chorizo is
very overpowering very but I didn't
taste the chorizo at all right so I
don't quite understand the dish in fact
I decided not to pay for that
wow I enjoying main courses yes nice to
see you we will thank you
really nice
the prawns were lukewarm the batter was
undercooked
and the novelty factor of the pipettes
not really Chris
how are you I'm very well enjoying the
food the batter was a bit soggy for my
damn so in terms of the modern Twist on
a Spanish dish with the papette is that
something that works for you or do you
think it's a little bit too once I got
into it but I just wasn't sure what you
had to do with it the big question is
are you gonna pay for them no no good to
see you thank you have you enjoyed the
main courses
honestly like one of those humbugs that
you'd always stop sucking good to see
you
in terms of presentation they both look
fantastic You've Got The Rustic
old-fashioned charm and this one here
and with a modern twist the secret is to
get the pipette
squeeze and Pull and then into the mouth
that's delicious
really delicious it's quite interesting
that chive mayonnaise against that
crispy batter the sweetness of the prawn
that works very very well right elgato's
these are cooked on a skewer the fresh
tomato sauce at the bottom
the idea is to squeeze the juice out the
head mix that in with a tomato and then
dip the prawn
really good flavor and the tomato sauce
works with sweetness of the prawn
however my only slight concern with this
plate is oil everywhere it was down to
me I'll go for the prawns with a pipette
they've tried something really
adventurous here and I have to say with
the chime mayonnaise it does work lovely
but it's not up to me whoever has the
most diners paying for the food tonight
will be crowned the F word's best local
Spanish restaurant
the results yeah I tried both issues I
thought they were fantastic
okay let's find out how you did JB
please the results so let's start off
with
Elgato nego
Simon and match the number of customers
out of 25 that are happy to pay yeah for
their starters it's
oh
wow 19 out of 25 well done well done
that's very good very good indeed now
payback JP give it a spice in your
chorizo so they wanted more spice the
ones that didn't pay the steadier under
season 19 loved it clearly yeah okay
good great start 19 out of 25. okay
the number of customers out of 25 that
are willing to pay for your starter
is
oh
wow
wow wow wow that is a surprise
9 out of 25.
why
tusugi soggy yeah what do you mean the
salad or the batter no the batter the
batter yeah I thought those prawns were
delicious I loved that little modern
Twist of the pepper I thought it was
unique but you must keep that batter
crisper yeah Do not drop your head now
that was only 25 to cook for now you've
got 50 to cook for Clear down yeah get
ready for the main course well done okay
okay bye next on the menu will El Guetta
Negra manage to hold their nerve and
stay in the lead this is not a racer
every single play counts yeah in the
recipe challenge Kelly Brook dresses to
impress oh I've got some Prada Mary
James on is that not appropriate
and I risk my life searching for one of
Spain's greatest Seafoods [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
now both Russians are going to be
cooking their main courses first up Lola
Rojo
in their South London restaurant Antonio
and Christina are determined to make
their food authentic the idea of the
restaurant was to mix
everything made from scratch they serve
octopus fresh from Galicia and suckling
pig from Salamanca coming from Barcelona
Antonio and Christina have a passion for
seafood so there's signals of this
tonight is Costa Brava fish stew
Antonio starts by dusting the turbot and
sea bass fillets in flour salt and
pepper thank you
fries the fish adding chopped onion
garlic and paprika it's nice for the
color and it's nice for the flavor no
next he grates the Tomato use the plum
tomato because the flavor of this tomato
I think is better he adds fish talk some
bold potatoes and clams to thicken the
stew Antonio creates a Piccata paste
he makes his saffron roast almonds fried
bread garlic and flat leaf parsley grind
it into a paste and adds it to the stew
it's simmered for a minute and is ready
to go
Costa Brava fish stew served
so Antonio the name of the restaurant
came from where
okay your first girlfriend you named
your restaurant of your first girlfriend
and does Christina know that no
Simon the sticker behind this dish what
is it
Irish combination of the soup yeah and
the sour dressing of the vinaigrette
yeah the texture in it as well here's
what Elgato negro is cooking tonight
El Greta negro is a tiny Tapas
restaurant in rippenden but head chef
Simon has huge aspirations in his London
days he had 35 chefs working for him but
now with a small team of four Simon
relies heavily on the right hand man
Matt stick him in front of the stove and
just wind him up funny girls all night
so it's perfect so he's got the looks
and I've got the brains I've always sort
of had the passion and desire to feel
from being able to cook but Simon has
just pushed me that a little bit further
like you said he's got the brains and
I've got the looks so let's make lots of
money you know what I mean check on boys
is sea bass with a warm potato Rosemary
and olive oil soup
first Simon fries sliced Charlotte
potatoes in butter with baby spinach
he sweats Down chop shallots and garlic
next he adds peeled and sliced potatoes
Rosemary and fish top and simmers for 15
minutes
the mix adding olive oil and seasoning
to skin the tomatoes he blanches them in
boiling water I normally count 14
seconds that won't be out loud that'll
be in my head for the vinaigrette he
reduces show vinegar then add sultanas
olive oil toasted pine nuts the diced
tomatoes and chopped parsley
seasoned the sea bass and Fries till
golden I want to stay nice and straight
sea bass with a warm potato Rosemary and
olive oil soup served
so Simon you're mixing the Vegas spinach
in with the potatoes last minute yeah
this is about 1970s using Rings yeah I
just thought I saw it to full because
it's got a soup in there okay excellent
Antonia would you put Spanish food in a
ring not not too much no not too much
the only ring you put is on your wife's
finger yes I love that paprika there's a
smoker paprika yes it's more paprika but
I thought with the starter you told me
you didn't like smoked paprika yeah
paprika Chef hey only for this for this
dish
is that it you happy with it that's it
yeah okay that looks fantastic well done
yeah really good okay hold on well done
well done off pjb let's go
so I think they should be in the Spanish
of their own game do you think your wife
Christina will leave you if you lose to
the English she's very passionate yes
yes if she does leave you can always go
back to your ex-girlfriend Lola can't
you
very nice thank you that looks lovely go
well done good table one please now six
more
this is fascinating Antonio had a really
bad start and his head went down and
sort of started becoming a little bit
more demoralized however he started to
pull it back the fish stew is absolutely
delicious I'm so impressed by Antonio's
attitude because he seems to bounce back
immediately which is a really good sign
so he's down and he's definitely not out
El ghetto negro that main course is
something quite interesting about that
he's got the 30 potatoes mixed with the
spinach this really nice delicious
potato and rosemary soup topped off of
this wonderful sea bass that's got these
really nice acidic raisins bizarre
combination but I think it really works
what's the next step after this last
next four got a four going now Force
after that yeah yes and we're halfway
there yeah wait and trust me this is not
a racer every single play counts yeah we
made the next half as good as the first
half yeah excellent thank you now Goose
Barnacles taste absolutely fantastic but
they're incredibly difficult to get your
hands on
I'm in galithia on the northwest coast
of Spain on the hunt for one of the
reasons the most sought after Delicacies
or Goose Barnacles
they're delicious expensive everything a
gourmet ingredient should be
but they're also at the bottom of a 300
foot cliff
oh my God the fast flowing water of the
Atlantic makes the goose Barnacles
stronger fatter and tastier to eat
the app sailing into it is the only way
to reach them oh my God this is insane
the powerful cones of the Atlantic are
not something to mess with
[Music]
once the waves Retreat I've got just 30
seconds before the return to spot the
goose Barnacles and wrench them off the
rocks
my guy tells me that if I hear a whistle
he's at the sea is coming crashing back
in and I have to get out the way fast
[Music]
the waves are knocking me all over the
place
I can see the goose Barnacles but I keep
on being pushed in the wrong direction
finally I've got my footing
[__] me you gotta be quick
I'm trading so hard on the prize I
forget the first simple rule
[Music]
listen for the whistle
[__]
I've lost the [__] stick
gracias thank you
[Music]
you need a license to collect Goose
Barnacles like this but I was quickly
starting to think who'd want one given
the risks
breaking them off the rock turns out to
be the easy part I've only collected a
few handfuls when disaster strikes
everything I collected was lost to the
Sea
bag's gone
this is by far the most dangerous
fishing trip I've ever been on
I only managed a couple of handfuls
before the tide filled the cove
that was hard work
I mean seriously hard work you're
holding on
and then when the wave wipes you out
you're trying to focus on the grip but
everything's just so slippy down there
looks nothing down there two and a half
three meters high when he comes in it
comes in Big Time whoa
be hot
[Music]
a great joint job look at them
they're beautiful what does that mean
when they're just slightly red
the quality is the best the quality is
the best I'm gonna show you how to do
the perfect Passover
tapa style yeah
right the ultimate Tapas now
traditionally cooked in sea water so no
salt in there whatsoever
first I'm going to ball him in the sea
water with bay leaves and a little bit
of olive oil cook them for one minute
they say here in Spain as long as it
takes you to say the Lord's Prayer once
they're cooked I need to remove their
tough skins all right the secret is to
peel them when they're warm
finish them a Sherry sauce with shallots
bay leaves and a touch of fresh pepper
definitely no salt this is where we've
got to be really quick a touch of Sherry
nice
couple of tablespoons of cream
bring that up to the boil add the Rind
and the juice of one lemon
and just squeeze
and [__] in there and then a couple
tablespoons of the cooking liquor that
lets down the cream and the secret here
is to give a really nice delicate
balance lemon out and pepper bears in
now literally in the cream for 30
seconds and finish with fresh parsley
really important to go on that cream for
literally 30 seconds
any longer than that that we like having
a mouthful of elastic bands
right gentlemen
slightly different
it is incredible The Taste they are
actually loving it are they fishing
tomorrow
if they find my bag yeah I want my 300
[__] Euros back yeah okay yeah
[Music]
good last time okay yep make it work
yeah
good hold on I get some water guys well
done tonight is up to the diners if they
don't like it they don't pay
the fish was cooked Perfection the olive
oil and the wilted spinach all tasted
great and it looks superb I thought that
the sultanas or raisins they were cooked
in I think vinegar either white wine
vinegar or something like that and that
was really overpowering
the fish stew was absolutely amazing a
little bit on the salty side
um but but really really nice and the
fish was cooked perfectly the fish stew
um was very well balanced very well
seasoned um there's a very nice taste of
saffron without being overpowering and
the fish was very well cooked
right Elgato negro sea bass
terms of flavor
sea bass tastes nice
um don't really get the potato on potato
the soup with the set of potatoes that
doesn't quite make sense however what
does lift the dish is there's wonderful
raisins and pine nuts on the top of the
sea bass
this is a classic fish stew nothing
glamorous just great bold flavors
that's lovely perfectly seasoned fish
too it's gone really Ultra Modern on the
starter but for the main cause he's
pulled it back a bit two really good
dishes it'll be interesting to see what
the diners prefer it was down to my
choice I'd go with the fish stew
so the results are in right Simon
um see bass yeah how well do you think
you did out of 50. or 40. about 40. with
such a great start you feel less
confident only 40 not 50 but more nerve
essentially more nervous nervous yeah
yeah Antonio
the fish stew out of 50. how well do you
think you've done 14 40 yeah okay uh JB
please
okay let's go I'll get a negro first yes
the number of customers there that are
happy to pay for your sea bass out of
50.
is
well done 32 out of 50. good news very
good news
the
um 18 customers that didn't pay feedback
please uh too much vinegar too much
vinegar yeah Simon happy with that 32
out 50. uh
I wanted to get to fully yeah okay
Antonio
the number of guests that are happy to
pay for your fist 2 out of 50
is
[Music]
38 out of 50. well done
really well done
really well done indeed
things when you combine the scores yes
there's only four points in it now
there's 25 covers each to cook for the
desserts yes
that means every plate matters and now
this is neck and neck
okay slow down get ready for dessert
good job really good job
now time for the part of the show where
I take on the celebrity and their
favorite dish and tonight it's Kelly
Brook taking me on with their stuffed
peppers what I reckon it's her who's
gonna get stuffed are you ready oh
really yes I'm excited this is this
proper challenge now what are you
cooking today my darling okay I'm doing
stuffed peppers right it's the dishes
excuse me delicious sorry delicious
you're doing a stuffed pepper I'm doing
a stuffed Tomato right okay but please
don't copy me
just tried and tested you grew up with
the love of food I did indeed my mom's a
fantastic cook actually and what kind of
things the mum used to cook when you're
a kid
um roast dinners and
um stinky pie she cooks everything from
Indian food to Chinese food so I sweat
the onions off a little bit of color
Touch of allspice and cinnamon Cook Out
the spices otherwise these are real raw
flavor across the mint probably so hot
pretty much ready to start making the
mince now I think you live with Danny
yes your long-term boyfriend yeah yes
rugby star he's a lot younger than you
does he keep on your toes a lot younger
about a few years I'm eight years older
than my wife Tana oh yeah she gives me
my toes in a big way I mean a massive
way okay he's no news younger than you
so he keeps you on your toes or
stilettos I like to think I'll give him
a run for his money show me your kitchen
shoes what have you got on oh I've got
some Prada Mary James on is that not
appropriate right you blanch your
peppers in boiling water and large mine
in boiling water to take the skin off so
peeled I'm gonna cut the tops off now
and then scrape out the insides I've
just put in half a teaspoon of this
cinnamon yup a little pinch of mince a
little pinch of oregano just to kind of
flavor them in and you've got freshmen I
prefer dried mint I think it's tastier
ready don't you um do you know what when
freshmen's available over dried I'd
rather go fresh all the time is that
just because you're a bit of a snob
there how far for me to stop trust me
because I want to win now I'm toasting
my pine nuts in with the mints yeah I'm
gonna add
um half a cup of rice
chop the remaining bits of tomato up
two-thirds minced one-third rice and
then just finish that with a little zest
of lemon
and lemon juice what's that they're
making a little bit drizzle to go over
the peppers you are so technical you
know that
do you like eating food like this so do
you like pumpkin food I'll eat anything
because you make fancy food don't you
it's
did you say Posh food gives you gas
it was horrendous so Kelly's put feta
cheese at the bottom I'm going at the
top of my tomatoes with a feta now
that's what I was gonna do put mine in
the bottom right the peppers and the
tomatoes now go in the oven for half an
hour we come back and the blind tasters
get to taste them
next on the menu will Lola Rocco
continue their fight back with their
dessert to become the F word's best
local Spanish restaurant every plate
make sure you're exactly over it yeah
you're only four points behind yeah come
on
and find out if Kelly Brook's peppers
have stuffed me in the recipe challenge
the winner is
um
[Music]
[Applause]
right welcome back to the f word now
time for the results of the recipe
challenge excited very excited
they do look alright actually they do
look good what do you think it looks
fantastic off you go think of your job
JB thank you good job
there you go
should we start with this one yeah
I'm a big fan of Cindy yeah me too oh
and a bit of feta I think should we try
the next one I think that one looks
nicer this looks a little bit burnt on
the outside
the aftertaste of the meat to me very
good though I'm so terrified I can't
even feel you he's got that little smoke
on his face okay come on then give me
the good news and deliver Kelly the bad
news all right so um what was the score
it's four to one of course it'll be four
seasons
yeah that's really bad
um so
the winner is
um
come on then Kitty
[Applause]
Are you
seriously
oh Jesus Christ and my seat you're right
the rice wasn't cooked properly why do
they like candy they love the spices the
cinnamons and all that stuff I'm about
the dried herbs I put fresh herbs in
mine I put love into mine you just put a
lot of anger
I love your love your food four one not
three two four
can we have a rematch
oh Jesus I'm busy I've got a move on but
it was nice working with you
right all right congratulations I've
been stuffed do me a favor get out my
kitchen
champagne please
right now it's time for my dessert
churros and chocolate
chew us with hot chocolate the Spanish
equivalent to our Donuts hot sticky and
Incredibly Moorish first off the hot
chocolate 300 milliliters of double
cream vanilla pod
cinnamon stick chili
orange zest heat and Infuse
let's train 150 grams of dark chocolate
melt
the churrosto 200 milliliters of water
50 grams of butter melt add flour to the
mixer
with a pinch of salt
pour in the melted butter and mix to a
smooth paste
Piping Bag
fill
chill
hot pan vegetable oil pipe
snip
the secret now is to get the dough
really nice and crispy
[Applause]
the sugar and ground cinnamon coat
chocolate
[Music]
[Applause]
cheer us with hot chocolate
done
both brigades are making my Spanish
dessert recipe
on your menu I haven't done it yet but
we'd love to do them very nice the
scores are close everything rests on
this last course
oh yes there's only four points
different in this let's go
if they'll get a Negra take the title
tonight it will Propel this tiny Place
into the big time I don't want to go all
that way to you know do a half half a
job so we we've got our sights set on
winning it
I'm victory for Lola Rocco will mean a
local London restaurant becomes a star
in the capital to win the competition
will be exciting that the achievement is
amazing so gentlemen I'm telling you
Simon these last dishes here okay are
going to determine who's first who's
second yeah every plate make sure you're
exactly over it yeah
you're only four points behind yeah come
on churros are a classic Spanish street
food but I think they make a great
dessert
they're deceptively tricky to make but
well worth the effort now why are your
churros bigger than Simon's why yeah
because we need four points more good
service please seven sixteen not too
many in there Antonio needs to be
careful too many in the fryer and they
won't cook properly
four more way this is the last table yes
okay last two portions back okay should
we go excellent
right chores Elgato negro can they beat
the Spanish at their own classic dessert
a lot smaller
cooked in the center
sauce
they're good right
wow
that's surprising a little bit too big
but more importantly that is raw that
tip there is just cooked
taste wise fantastic chocolate sauce
brilliant however I'm absolutely
devastated of the rawness and for me the
big question across these desserts is
why don't they cook one and taste it
sauce was lovely and gooey and really
really nice and the donuts were lovely
as well really lots of cinnamon on them
so they were really delicious fantastic
chocolate fantastic
I liked the cinnamon flavor on the
churros however the dough is sticky
inside I don't know whether that was
because it was undercooked or whatever
but it was a bit sticky inside the
chocolate was fine but for me the
tourists was undercooked so the results
are in and it's time to find out who's
our winner tonight uh Simon how well do
you think you did uh not as confident as
the main cause if I'm honest no Antonio
uh you grew up with them out of 25
customers how well do you think you did
15 15
16. yeah okay let's find out how you did
uh JB thank you right let's start off
with La Roca
now for desserts the number of customers
happy to pay
out of 25 is
blimey
14 out of 25.
yeah
11 customers
didn't pay why not one main reason
undercooked
did you taste first one second one my
test
so I'll get the Negro that means if you
get more than 10
than you are the F word's best local
Spanish restaurant
okay the number of customers that are
happy to pay
for your dessert out of 25
foreign
[Applause]
are straight into fourth place on the f
word leaderboard but will their score
earn them a place in the semi-final
s I'm searching the country to find our
best local restaurants
Britain's independent restaurants serve
fantastic food in the heart of our
communities
each week I'm choosing two unsung
culinary Heroes to compete in the f word
kitchen
make this the best service of your
entire life so far in my quest to find
the F word's number one local restaurant
I've crowned the best local Italian
French and Indian restaurants I mean I'm
just shaking inside deadworth's top
local Thai and Chinese restaurants we
give this home to Manchester and last
week El Gato Negra from Yorkshire took
the Spanish title it's 23 out of 20.
hey
this seat we're celebrating food from
all over the Americas
making and saltfish to steak from
Burgers to fajitas you love the food of
this huge meat loving continent
and tonight two of your favorite
restaurants will be cooking in the f
word kitchen it's Argentina versus the
Caribbean who will win the battle of the
Americas and the chance to go through to
the next round and remember
Ernesto Paddington is a competition yes
yes may the best chef win also on the
show I'm off the North America to track
down a delicious delicacy snow goose
I've done some really crazy things for
food in my life but nothing quiet to
this extent you know that yeah yeah
in the recipe challenge in right takes
me on with his Caribbean Jerk Chicken
and that's if he manages to keep all
these fingers
we cut yourself oh Jesus
foreign
[Applause]
excellent good evening welcome good to
see you guys Barrington how are you sir
I'm fine good to see you welcome to the
f word what's the secret success behind
Discovery Bay what is it basically the
heart and the passion and everybody
loves working there how Ernesto yeah
Chef the secret success behind Santa's
Maria what is it Argentina made is
something special I ripped the kitchen
apart last night put this Grill
especially for you look it better be
good yes yes don't set the place on fire
no no okay please no all four of you
yeah it's tonight yeah your child to
show everybody how good you are let's
get cooking tonight Discovery Bay and
Santa Maria delcia will be competing in
the f word kitchen this is how they got
here
early this year I asked you to log on to
the f word website and nominate your
favorite local restaurants
the response has been absolutely
phenomenal you told us about nearly 5
000 different places you love to eat
for tonight's America's heat you
nominated your favorite restaurants
serving food from North Central and
South America
such a huge range of Cuisines from
across the Atlantic my team and I really
had a work cut out it's all freshly
cooked and the meat is of very high
quality from Argentina to Mexico from
Caribbean to Cuban we Whittle down your
UK restaurant nominations looking for
the very best we're traveling across the
country really putting these nominated
restaurants under severe scrutiny and
after a month of searching it became
obvious that two of your nominations
stood out
wait to put them to the test first up
Santa Maria Del Sur in Battersea
this hugely popular Argentine Steakhouse
is run by Jose aldar and f word viewers
gave it rave reviews hello how are you
fine and
you see and now first name is Jose good
to see you Argentina from Argentina the
secret success behind the Russian is
what
Argentine meat with some nice wine from
Argentina also here the people just you
know they come they ask for the steak
they receive the steak they enjoy it
with wine and that's it just takes on
the grill
and that Grill is manned by head chef
Ernesto La Brava would you prefer
cooking is it fillet a ribeye
Ernesto was studying to be a lawyer but
jacked it in to go to Chef School in
Havana it's quite different what is in
my life but yes I'm very happy to be
cooking Argentina food in London
Santa Maria Del Sur is famous in the
neighborhood for its delicious steaks
they opened in 2006 and have been
packing in customers ever since I wrote
a mistake ordered it medium rare came
out beautifully cooked nice and
succulent in the middle you know great
sort of flavors on the outside good
quality meat is essential to the success
of Santa Maria so they insist on
importing only the very best steaks I
think the quality of the meat is
Argentina is very good because the grass
is very good the weather's conditions
are fantastic the average time or steak
is hanging it's between 20 and 28 days
so the taste of the meat is very nice
I try some traditional Argentine pasties
empanadas
where are they made here
everything from me the empanadas the
start one chicken one beef so Savory not
too spicy English properly say stay in
the rest yeah a Russian is true to my
own heart not a vegetarian in sight
anywhere so far so delicious but next up
is the real test my rib eye straight
from Ernesto's Grill
lovely thank you wow
steak's nice and thick honestly that
charcoal flavor is extraordinary pretty
good and so nice to see it being done
properly
two seconds come over guys
um so
thank you and that was uh that was nice
very nice indeed um my issue is that the
American category is so diverse because
there's such a huge variety of
restaurants across the board so my
decision is
congratulations
I mean really congratulations and that
was delicious really good and
beautifully cooked season Bruce Lee
cooked brilliantly and more importantly
flavor was extraordinary thank you good
luck
Argentine wine Argentine beef and then
they're passionate about Argentina look
we're in the middle of bastard City yeah
amazing I mean really good
and you need to try to cook the most
perfect steaks for that moment I am very
very happy so Santa Maria Del surf are
through but who'll be joining them
you're ever winning nomination in
America's category was an extraordinary
Caribbean in Huddersfield
[Music]
Discovery Bay is a tiny but intriguing
restaurant serving Caribbean Classics
like Aki and saltfish and curried goats
it's owned by Barrington Douglas what
makes Discovery beer successful is the
relaxed warming atmosphere the light
reggae and the Soulful Vibes in the
background you feel as if you're in the
Caribbean and then when you stab your
fork into your meat and your tears and
you think you know what these people
have put heart soul and passion into
everything that we're doing I've been
here so many times I've practiced
menu
as dedicated his entire life to
Discovery Bay he decided as a teenager
that he wanted to open a restaurant and
saved up for over 20 years he even
remortged his house to make his dream
come true at the age of 19 I said right
every hundred pound I earn I'm going to
put 20 pounds away and the dream was to
open a restaurant and after 20 21 years
they accumulate the summer money and now
I'm living my dream
barrington's clearly a man with
Incredible commitment but is his modern
taken Caribbean Classics good enough for
the f word restaurant I sent f word made
to djb along to try it out welcome to
school there thank you thank you thank
you would you like to follow me to the
bath please
the decor is 70s retro and there's
Reggae on the stereo eating a Discovery
Bay is a very chilled affair
the Rayleigh back is the first time that
I've been escorted to a sofa to take my
my drink orders I find it very unusual
but very cool as well hello guys
is
going to be excited today
Barrington Cook's classic Jamaican
dishes inspired by his grandmother but
with an added British twist we got a
vegetable called callaloo but it's like
an English spinach so I'll do Caribbean
spices with English spinach
one of the best sellers on Discovery
Bay's menu is rum pork Baron and cook
one up for JB what is so special about
this dish is the sauce has been made
with a bit of rum you really give these
flavors this taste which is absolutely
incredible hi Gordon JB filled me in
this was a tough category but Discovery
Bay past JB's taste test with flying
colors hello Discovery Bay a good
evening is that Barrington yeah speaking
Yeah barrington's Gordon Ramsay how are
you I'm fine fine very fine what does
your restaurant Discovery Bay do that
any other Caribbean restaurant doesn't
do what Discovery Bay does we've got
heart
um everybody everybody everybody in here
has got passion well your customers are
certainly loyal the feedback has been
extraordinary you only have 36 seats in
your restaurant yes yeah you're gonna
have to focus on 50. congratulations
just through
yes we're dying room excellent thank you
very much thank you very much it means
the world to us all thank you very very
much
born happy Barrington we're in
we're in we're in
[Music]
I'm very excited you can tell when I'm
excited the cheeks go
they go right up so from your
nominations I've chosen two
extraordinary restaurants
all the f word diners be Charmed by
Discovery Bay's Caribbean heart and soul
or will they prefer the delicious
Simplicity of Santa Maria Del Sur
next on the menu the two Russians battle
out for the America's title
there's one team celebrating too early
you can stop dancing now maybe you can
show me a few moves after the main
course yeah
and I head to North America in search of
a delicious Canadian delicacy snow goose
but first I need to learn the language
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back in London at the f word
restaurants
and tonight we're crossing the Atlantic
and celebrating the amazing flavors of
North South and Central America after
searching for months all over the
country we Whittle down your nominations
to two fantastic restaurants
Argentine Grill House Santa Maria Del
Sur in South London and Caribbean
restaurant Discovery Bay in Huddersfield
25 portions of each is not a race first
table Santa Maria final order four
covers away table one four empanadas
four ribeye four Peach thank you
Barrington on all the full coverage
table four four chicken Caesar salad
four pork four peaches yes chef tonight
I've challenged both brigades to cook
their best chili and chicken starter
nice on Ernesto yeah I love that smile
you've got when you're cooking yeah
you're always happy in the kitchen
outside you weren't very happy now in a
kitchen bang you liked up
oh at Santa Maria Del Sur in South
London every night is party night and
their classic Argentine food is a huge
hit with the locals you can hear it's
quite a quite lively place perfectly
[Music]
Santa Maria cooking chicken and chili
empanadas a classic Argentinian starter
they fill the pastry cases with chicken
mixed with peppers onions eggs tomatoes
olives and mixed herbs
they pinch the Casey's shut and deep fry
until golden
they serve with the Watercress fennel
and chili salad and garnish with lemon
what's the secret behind a really good
Empanada I think pastry good chicken
good flavor easy to make that's it right
Barrington talk to me yes sure who
taught you to cook first who was it
there was all boys and um I was a bird
so she pulled me to one side and showed
me out how can your mum think that
you're okay
and she had a special technique with The
Wooden Spoon what was that well at the
beginning my mum says um what you need
to do you need to watch the part and
every time I used to open their mouth
and say something she was just here I
didn't ask you to talk I said to watch
the part it worked
it did discipline
Discovery Bay in Huddersfield is run by
Barrington Douglas whose mum taught him
everything there is to know about
Caribbean cuisine my passion for cooking
started off at home with my mom cooking
there was five boys no girls and there
was one day my mom says right I want
somebody to learn how to cook so she
pulled me to one side and that's where
it started gentle giant Barrington is
Keen to pass on his knowledge he mentors
local young people teaching them how to
cook
it treats me like one of his sons he's
like a dad to me and I'd do anything for
him Discovery Bay starter is jerk
chicken Caesar Salad Barrington fried
chicken marinated in jerk seasoning made
with Scotch bonnet peppers garlic black
pepper cinnamon nutmeg Thyme and
allspice he dresses mixed leaf salad in
Caesar sauce
[Music]
what's so special about this recipe what
is it is the seasoning on the jerk
chicken we'll do a lot of Jerk Chicken
in in the Caribbean yes but this is
where I'm just trying to bring it to a
little bit of a European taste as well
with the Caesar salad so would you say
your interpretation is more modern more
modern so more dangerous more dangerous
accent uh Cynthia in terms of being in
the middle of pasta it's like a little
sort of communal pocket of Argentina
yeah we are really friendly I wear like
a small family yeah we're going to dance
and salsa sometimes amazing yeah are you
teaching him or is he teaching you he's
teaching you ah so you're the one little
hot Shooters
okay good four more excellent and how
old when you first started cooking
um my first time seven years old seven
years ago what was the first thing you
cooked one it roast beef roast beef yes
North and South America are stuffed with
the most amazing ingredients here's one
of the most delicious
[Music]
Canada in the northern tip of the
American continent is home to some of
the most delicious wildfowl in the world
[Music]
with Christmas coming up and Goose one
of my favorite festive Foods I couldn't
be in a better place
Beck where almost a million wild snow
geese stop off once a year as they
migrate south
always been a big fan of British gooks
however the snow goose is a Canadian
ancestor and they say taste wise is in a
completely different League I can't wait
to try it
I'm in the town of nominee where snow
goose is so famous it's like the local
mascot there are thousands here so I'd
like to think they only have the best
wild snow goose on the local restaurant
menus
[Music]
very light in color
that unfortunately was a bit of a
letdown I was expecting more of a sort
of richer gameier slightly Livery flavor
that's the kind of goose you can get
anywhere certainly not worth coming all
the way to Quebec 4 that's for sure
Goose has too much fat on it to be a
wild delicacy
so I want to grill the head chef
Frederick to find out where it came from
how are you I'm all right you yeah
everybody thank you happy to be here
yeah but then my Goose arrived so that
is snow geese no that's farmer geese
that's Farm geese why are you serving me
Farm geese when you've got hundreds of
thousands of them in your front garden
because it's illegal illegal it's not
legal we eat at home but we can serve at
the restaurant we can't serve the
restrooms but that's Madness from a chef
to Chef yeah wild that is completely
different it's not the same flavor chalk
and cheese yeah
because of the Canadian authorities
can't monitor the health of wild snow
geese they don't allow restaurants like
this one to sell it
so the only way I can actually go and
eat
a wild snow goose let's go and shoot the
bloody thing myself yeah
to maximize my chances of finding a wild
snow goose I headed out of town and
further up the Saint Lawrence River
this vast Waterway is 70 kilometers wide
and is prime feeding ground for
migrating birds
Daniela chance has been hunting here
since he was a child look
thousands half a million half a million
yeah my God all I want to taste is one
that's all I want is one
a remote island in the middle of the
river is one of Daniel's best hunting
spots
we start at 5am the next morning to get
into position before the snowgey
spotters trudging away across the
riverbed as soon as the tide goes out
the Tide's gone out
and this mud is bloody deep no yeah
really bloody
oh my God
a few hours ago these hides below ground
were buried deep underwater
I've done some pretty crazy things in my
life in order to get food but I've never
done this I've sat in the middle of the
river in a box holy crap
we sit under cover of Darkness waiting
for the snow geese to fly in
so when we see them do we dive down do
we if they really really important yeah
to show our faces because they're pretty
smart
Daniel mimics the call of the geese to
try and attract passing Birds
go
no go
cheers yeah
an hour later as the sun begins to burst
through the clouds the snowgees start to
fly in
and arrive on the riverbed in the
thousands
[Music]
[Applause]
I just wish one or two of them would
land near us
but there must be what how many there
probably between 10 and 15 000 snow
geese there
oh [__]
snow geese have incredibly sharp sight
and a keen sense of danger which was
keeping them well away from us so we've
got 15 000 geese sat there and five
thousand sat there
and we're stuck here yeah who put the
box here
was it the French what the [__]
all I want is one
one little goose
it's the distances these wild birds fly
that makes their meat lean and delicious
to eat but as they move around the river
they were proving too clever for us
you think it'd be a lot easier to catch
them but no they're not easy to guess
they are very very intelligent birds
Plan B
if I wanted to taste this amazing
delicacy I had no option but to find
another hunting spot
[Music]
hey guys yes all the food's looking
fantastic you've got four more away now
please yeah I mean last day was a four
yes yes uh Barry to make sure the last
table is as good as the first table yes
yes sure I wish Barrington they look
fantastic yeah all the stars out thank
you brilliant are you always this quick
yes I like to do it yeah do you have
rhythm yeah what's the first movie
taught you Cynthia
down show me Jesus no hold on sure
ah totally
later maybe you can show me a few moves
after the main course yeah yeah Cynthia
get ready I've got size 15 feet
very light and not too filling so nice
for starter really lovely the chili
wasn't too strong just light and yeah
it's beautiful
hello how are you welcome to the f word
thank you very much
congratulations watching your team yes
it's great it's great it's great they
think they they are smiling enjoying the
time yeah it's a very passionate pair
they work very well together nice
chemistry yeah real good chemistry
argentinians are very proud nation very
proud
they play football
how you feel if you lose tonight it's
like uh not going to work up right it's
gonna be that yeah yes yes I think this
is the World Cup for us right everybody
could see him yeah okay thank you very
much
really nicely presented and tastes
fantastic really really pleased it was
really nice it was well dressed it was
fresh salads chicken was cooked really
well now good evening welcome good day
tell me how am I doing
um
good to see you how are you I'm very
well how do you think Barrington and the
Sean do I think they're doing really
well he's a kind of guy who can cope
Under Pressure how long have you known
each other over 15 years and what's so
special about Discovery Bay what is it
it's the heart and the saw that's gone
into the place and how much did tonight
mean to him and leaving here as a winner
that would mean a lot to laurenton and
it took a big risk in his life to put
money into the business so um to him
this will just put Iceland on a cake
enjoy my classes I look forward to
seeing you after thank you excellent
thank you
all right empanadas Santa Maria uh
classic our version of a Cornish pasty
ready chicken chili and olives with a
little chili salad with some eggs
hmm that's delicious really good
pastry's nice and crispy
filling is absolutely delicious nice
beautiful executed and stunning pastry
okay Discovery Bay jerk chicken Caesar
salad not what I expected to see from a
Caribbean restaurant however this guy is
ambitious and Incredibly confident
chicken's really nice the more you eat
the chicken the more the intense flavor
the jerk season really really good two
stunning dishes absolutely neck and neck
personally if I had to choose one I'd go
for the Empanada absolutely delicious if
the diners don't like their starters
they don't pay the results are in right
now Barrington
um out of 25 how well do you think your
Caribbean jerk chicken Caesar salad went
down 50 50. interesting
okay JB please
uh let's start off with uh Santa Maria
yeah the number of customers are happy
to pay for your starters out of 25 is
23 out of 25. well done
it's amazing
well done that is a fantastic score for
the starters
um what do they like about the most JB
um they love the combinations the
feeling was very good so they absolutely
love it
okay Barrington
the number of customers are happy to pay
for your jerk Caesar salad out of 25 is
23 out of 25. well done
well done that is extraordinary
absolutely amazing feedback from the
Cesar salad was what um they think the
chicken was very tender
all of you have done fantastically well
23 out 25 now
is where it really goes up a different
level really push the boat out yeah well
done great start clear down start up
main course next on the menu it's
carabin run pork versus Argentinian
steaks but with the scores level which
are the brigades from the Americas will
come out on top bloody smoke in here
honestly it's like you're sending smoke
signals
in our Caribbean recipe challenge in
right has some career advice for parking
you should be doing step
and when I finally bag a delicious
Canadian snow goose
[Music]
[Applause]
right now both Russians are going to
cook their main courses first up
Discovery Bay
at Discovery Bayne Huddersfield
barrington's menu combines classic
Caravan recipes with European
ingredients
we've got the specials where I try to
fuse fool together so we might use
pastas linguine rocket leaves
barrington's ambitious approach to
Caravan dining has been a hit with the
Yorkshire locals
[Music]
it does it it's just like something it's
just like your mother's cooking if not
better sorry
check on
thank you one room Park
barrington's main course is one of his
most popular dishes run pork with sweet
potatoes
Barrington starts by marinating pork
medallions with fresh thyme Rosemary
black pepper chopped garlic and dark rum
for the rum gravy heats up beef stock
and adds red green and yellow peppers
we've got the red yellow and green so we
have got the rasaman colors and the
colors of the Caribbean islands as well
running through there and what we've got
here we've got the old Jamaica room
Daryl do next he griddles the port
medallions and sliced sweet potato
he adds the pork medallion to the rum
gravy and finishes with cream
he serves with steamed vegetables
smells absolutely beautiful I work here
and please
run pork with sweet potatoes served
so Barrington
the secret behind this make yours is
what it's a stock base it lets a
reduction of the stock
um
what's the heat at the back that's a
little bit of Scotch bonnet pepper in
there okay when you're standing in front
of that Grill that's a very difficult
thing to operate in Battlefield how'd
you get the temperature of the steaks
cooked perfectly what is it we need to
move the grill all the time
depends how good the people once so
you're not touching the steaks it's
always this yes your tongue it is the
same when you touch your hands yep when
you touch here yes
medium Italian I'm well done I'm well
done here's what Santa Maria cooking
tonight
at Santa Maria Del Sur in South London
they use only the finest Argentinian
beef using Argentinian beef is one of
the best in the world because we have so
much nice grass nice weather the way the
cows eat the way they live makes the
beef that tasty and tender
you can really taste the difference to
any other beef that you need this is
really excellent table five
Santa Maria signature dish tonight is
Argentinian ribeye steak with
chimichurri sauce
for the chimichurri Ernesto chops
parsley and garlic and blends with olive
oil
really really nice
he adds bay leaves ground sweet red
pepper oregano sea salt and mixes
stirs in warm water to infuse the
flavors
he finishes with white wine vinegar and
chopped Red Onion the chimichurrier is
the real tasty sauce from Argentina
Ernesto Char girls an Argentinian ribeye
steak and Seasons with olive oil and sea
salt
not to wash
he says with a rocket and sugar snap
salad dresses with toasted sesame and
sunflower seeds chimichurri sauce on the
side and garnish of the steak with a
slice of roasted red pepper
Argentinian ribeye steak with
chimichurri sauce served
health and safety of family from having
an open fire in my kitchen so I've had a
special Grill installed why
what makes Argentinian beef so special
what is it on the weather's conditions
and is it one of the best things in the
world I think it's the best you think
it's the best yes why not do you think
it's better than Scottish uh yes yeah
you may be better than as a football but
I don't know about the states however
we'll find out later yeah yeah bloody
smoke in here what have you done to my
kitchen it's always like this yes all
the time all the time all the time
honestly it's like you're sending smoke
signals huh is that trying to put
Barrington off what's all that about no
yes
that's right Ernesto you happy with them
thank you right now back to Canada
Quebec in North America on the hunt for
one of the most delicious birds in the
world
no goose
almost a million descent on the salons
River for a few weeks each year so far
I'd had little luck shooting one
[Music]
a new day and Daniel takes me to a new
hunting spot this time thankfully on dry
land
so why don't you bring me here yesterday
in a nice little sort of Bunker than
being sat in the middle of a river
sometimes it's better there sometimes
it's better here it feels right here
yeah anyway we're we're well placed and
it's getting nice and white over there
isn't it yeah they begin to be maybe two
or three thousand now
so when they fly over I can shoot anyone
if you want to eat it yeah the gray ones
are much more better because they are
more tender because they're the
youngsters exactly we've just made it 10
times more difficult so it's not just
about shooting a snow geese no he's
looking for that great ones exactly
young great geese have migrated few
miles than older birds so the meat is
more tender
and long before we get our first chance
not bad order will come these ones here
aiming for a stray Goose on the move is
the best way to ensure we hit just one
with a clean shot
and finally one came our way
yes yes [__]
I've got my Goose but was it the right
age and the very best to eat brilliant
ah perfect young one for one young one
my God look at that baby there what and
how young is that is that the perfect
age it's uh a fresh fresh noodles of the
of the year
honestly I'm so pleased to get one
that's brilliantly we go finally ah we
got it excellent well done
beautiful Woods huh before I can cook
snow goose for the first time Daniel
shows me how to de-breast the bird
now to get the breasts off you'll just
have to pull like that and see
everything is coming it's incredible
and look how thin that fat is there's
hardly any fat on there
a lot darker than I expected yeah it's
like a red brown meat yeah like venison
and the breasts are quite thick as well
I thought I thought they'd be thin but
close to uh to an inch yeah it's
incredible
Christmas is fast approaching and gooses
were my favorite Birds to cook and I've
got a recipe that'll bring out this wild
meets Rich gamey flavor perfectly this
is the first for me a delicious lean
snow goose breast with a rich red wine
tomato sauce finished with soda potatoes
onions and garlic
First Slice the potatoes and parboil
with olive oil and a bit of salt pan on
for the goose
season the snow goose and fry it with
rosemary garlic and butter once it's
beautifully colored take it out of the
pan
now to go with the snow goose I'm going
to really nice red wine tomato sauce fry
some chopped onions and garlic that's
nice
then add red wine to the pan really
important to reduce the red wines down
to a syrup otherwise you've got that
sort of raw alcohol flavor in the sauce
tomatoes and chicken stock
and then the snow goose goes back to
finish cooking with some butter
[Music]
gives the sauce a nice glaze
the snow goose is Rich so the soda
potatoes will be very simple now the
secret to get our skin really nice and
crispy
they're fried with some chopped onion
garlic Thyme and butter
slice the snow goes nice and thinly
now put the sauce on top
definitely one of the most exciting
ingredients I've ever cooked I can't
wait to try it
that is so delicate yeah incredibly
tender it's really delicious yeah it's
really great that's given me a
completely different taste and
experience than I ever could imagine it
smells delicious it tastes delicious and
also it's very healthy yeah because it's
no fat no fat I'm really really happy
with that and what an amazing Discovery
and thank you I just need one more favor
I need you to redirect the snow goose
via Scotland so I don't have to travel
so far next time that is incredible but
that's really great yeah really good
away yeah they look great they smell
delicious
now your sauces start to get darker now
is that because you've changed the
recipe or are you just over reducing it
it's the juicing quite a bit yeah yeah
every plate got to look the same yeah
Ernesto thank you thank you well done
thank you pretty good thank you right
well done yeah clear down yep drink some
water job well done thank you Jeff
I really enjoyed the pub really nice
really well cooked and the sauce is
gorgeous flavors are amazing
um very Moorish very like you want to
lick your plate literally the sauce is
incredible
state was delicious very tender I like
the sauce that was with the chimichurri
I hadn't tried that before so it was
nice to try that the steak was Lush I
don't usually like rare steak to be
honest with you but um Changed My Views
probably
right Argentinian beef Santa Maria
beautifully cooked lovely color
sauce a little bit of grilled pepper on
there
it's cooked perfectly it's incredibly
juicy
mmm and packed full of flavor salad
unfortunately a little bit Bland
slightly boring
something nice eating raw onion with the
most amazing steak however Vanessa
really knows your stuff that
is perfection
Discovery Bay fill is a pork
with a creamy rum sauce vegetables sat
on a bed
of sweet potato
looks a little bit more complex
source of delicious pork is delicious as
well
and I'm so glad to put that rum in there
because that really sort of wakes up
that richness
um tough choices one if I was the diner
and I had to choose between them both
I have to say
I'd go for the steak
so the results are in right now
Barrington out of 50. give us another
45. 45 out of 50.
46 46. one more and Discovery Bay okay
good JB please results okay let's start
off with
Discovery Bay
so the number of customers they're happy
to pay for your pork dish is
[Music]
wow
30 out of 50. huh very good score
huh
the the 30 customers that loves it what
do they say yeah they love the favors
and they think it was very well seasoned
and the 20 customers that didn't pay
um overcooked slightly to dry I tasted
the pork I thought it was delicious yeah
yeah that's still a very respectful
score yeah yeah okay right it's Santa
Maria the number of customers are happy
to pay for your steak out of 50 is
thank you
it's 38 out of 50. congratulations
welcome
well done well done well done
congratulations
um so what do they like first about the
steak um they found the steak very
tender very tender 12 arm pain fruit
what do they say and some of them find
it overcooked overcooked yeah
okay well done 38 out of 50. fantastic
all four of you now cooking 25 portions
of the dessert so it is still Incredibly
Close yeah you can bring this back yeah
and you can lose it if you're not
careful sit down and get ready for
desserts yeah let's go
continue tonight's America's theme Ian
Wright is planning to score with
Caribbean Jerk Chicken in the recipe
challenge he was a hero on the pitch but
is he a jerk in the kitchen are you
ready I am ready um yes I'm ready Ian's
doing a traditional jerk chicken and I'm
doing my own version now is this mum's
recipe yes you know so I grew up with
and what's the secret behind it why do
you love it so much I like the spiciness
of it we're gonna do it in the oven here
it's normally done in a drum side of a
road I want to score this I'm very very
nervous about this knife is that how you
score it no I'm just taking my bone off
ah well I'm not going to bother with
that no um
and what other kind of dishes did mum
used to cook obviously the main one was
the rice and peas and chicken dumplings
yams green bananas and normally I
remember the average seasoned overnight
I'm gonna use cinnamon chili allspice
nutmeg cloves salt and pepper almost
like a bit of a dry rub first you seem
like you've got so much more stuff on
your stuff than me man
Jesus I want more stuff on mine but
don't copy me I'm not copying you but I
just don't like the way you're kind of
like moving ahead and it looks like
yours your season looks good
she's not ah
we cut yourself
oh Jesus
Ian this is positive news for me because
it makes me feel like I'm gonna win the
challenge you know what I think what
you've done is you've just got me
talking so much yeah that you know I
mean I'm using the knife trying to copy
you use the knife like all smooth and
cool that's like me trying to copy you
taking penalties thing is you're either
cool or you're not I know because a lot
for the family
um not really the most I do now is
spaghetti bolognese I never had a lot of
pasta when I was a kid it was very much
a hard food Jamaican food most of the
time
if I keep the fingers well away from
that that's it yeah good right what I'm
doing is they're out this is to go into
my secret Ian Wright jerk chicken sauce
um so I've got garlic in there spring
onions Scotch bonnet peppers thyme black
pepper everything I've got everything in
there
and uh this is what's going to give it
the spices the beautifulness now you're
presenting new Chat Show on Channel Five
yeah yes Michael Parkson said it was the
worst ever Chat Show on TV who said that
Michael Parker Michael Parkinson you
know East law is everyone yes what he's
got to do is he's just gotta you know I
mean just go gracefully he should be
doing step in baths now and then
motorized motorized wheelie things
Stella lives stair lifts that's what you
should be doing what I'm doing now is
I'm putting my sauce over the chicken so
it can get in there I'm really liking it
at the moment hopefully the taster will
like it roasting off the chicken and
then just finishing that with a couple
tablespoons of Leon Perrin now that dark
of the chicken makes a little bit more
spicy got a really good color on there
and then into a tray now you speak your
mind a lot like I do yes well you've got
it off the chest and deal with it there
and then sometimes you say stuff and you
just have to just have to try and get
the Poo back in the office that's all
you've got to do
come on chicken do it for me now your
man that likes to get on the top or the
bottom which one's going to give me the
most heat because you fried yours a lot
longer I'll go top then right now
they're both on the oven there for 20
minutes we come back and the blind
tasters will taste them I predict
Scotland won England nil
next on the menu will Santa Maria Del
Sur be able to hold their lead and
become the F word's best local America's
restaurant
that camel's too strong yeah no one's
gonna be able to eat it yeah
and find out if you're in right scores a
known goal in the recipe challenge
so the winner for today is come on
[Music]
right welcome back to the airport now
time for the results of the recipe
challenge you're excited I am it smells
delicious thank you yes I'm really
pleased with it
well I'm ready to go Moment of Truth
get your Jerk Chicken on there my son
will it be all right on the night off
you go good luck thanks a lot Gordon
she's gonna need it
oh this one's very different it's not
quite as crispy on the outside it's a
little bit sweeter yeah it's much
sweeter I'm quite nervous yeah I'm very
nervous I hate the results right JB so
the winner for today is come on
England or Scotland Scotland
[Applause]
that sauce is one of my best they really
love both okay and we're stacky to
sweets what can you do you [__] and you
know you are you love me one little
Ramsay I know I'll get you on something
at my kitchen
time for the brigades final challenge
dessert a perfect combination of peaches
a very popular fruit in Argentina and
rum the Caribbean's favorite drink
roasted peaches flammed in rum sweet
fruity and totally indulgent peaches
slice
hot pan caster sugar caramelize
peaches in and then just gently toss
them in the caramel
butter
and now for the rum
flambe woof
[Music]
lime cream
180 ML of double cream whisk
icing sugar
lime zest
[Music]
shortbread on the plate and then start
layering
icing sugar
roasted peaches with rum and lime cream
done
now Barrington yeah
Ernesto yes yes this is unbelievably
close okay yeah it can be won a lost on
dessert yeah keep it going yeah every
plate counts very nice Barrington they
look fantastic if that camel's too
strong on an esto yeah no one's gonna be
able to eat it yeah be very very careful
yeah nice light blonde caramel yeah yeah
good and remember
Ernesto Valentine it's a competition yes
yes sir may the best chef win
everybody win tonight will be a proud
achievement for Barrington and his team
all this time and effort that I put in
there it would just put the icing on the
cake and I'll just think we're doing
something right we're definitely doing
something right and for Santa Maria Del
Sur Victory will transform a restaurant
already famous in South London into a
national success story
win in this award will mean I think
that's it I mean it's nothing higher
yes watch that caramel yes that caramel
has to be absolutely delicious if you're
not happy with the camera you don't send
it yes yeah and the camera's not cooked
out properly they all stick together so
it can't be too thick go tilt the pan
there you go good man
that's better Ernesto thank you Jeff
yeah much better it's not a race geyser
a nest over the last table going out as
good as the first table Yeah Chef really
important yeah Jeff
it was absolutely amazing the peaches
were very sweet they really complemented
the biscuit base as well
cream was great and it counteracted the
Sweet Taste of the toffee that's really
nice right roasted peaches with lime
cream
that's delicious a nice taste of rum on
the peach
and the secret there is that I've got
this really nice caramel they haven't
overcooked the peaches but this really
nice rum flavor comes through with the
lime cream
delicious really really good indeed
now Discovery Bay again nice color on
the caramel
peaches cook nicely
count just a little bit undercooked
needed 30 more seconds in the pan
those peaches that Barrington cooked are
absolutely delicious the results are in
and it's time to find out who our winner
is tonight right at Barrington
very calm composed
I'm doing those amazing peaches yeah
no dancing no smiling no okay
JB please
thank you
okay Discovery Bay
the number
of customers they're happy to pay for
the dessert out of 25 yeah yes
congratulations 22 out of 25 that's
amazing
that is amazing
very good score indeed happy yes really
good yeah sure
okay good Santa Maria
did you get 15 or more you have one
let's see the number of customers that
are happy to pay for dessert
out of 25 is
is 25 out of 25. well done
it's amazing
fantastic that means 86 out of 100.
right at the top of the leaderboard
congratulations fantastic news Well Done
Cynthia well done
so Santa Maria Del surmed straight to
the top of the f word leaderboard
which means they're through to the
semi-finals